It's always important to plot your data.
Let's go through an example y.
I've got here eleven data points, which I've plotted on the right.
We might want to compute some summary statistics about this data set.
Such as its mean, variance, correlation coefficient, and line of best fit.
Now suppose I give you three more data sets with exactly the same
summary statistics, like this.
You'd expect that since these data sets have the same mean,
variance, correlation coefficient, and
line of best fit, that they look very similar when visualized.
Let's have a look now.
How similar are these data sets?
Not very.
We can see here the effect of curvature and
outliers have drastically thrown off our summary statistics.
This is something called Anscombe's quartet.
And demonstrates how important it is to always plot your data,
rather than relying on summary statistics alone.
Tools like matplotlib in Python or ggplot in R are great ways to
plot your data visually, allowing you to pick out visual patterns, trends, and
outliers during your analysis.
Hopefully, this example has shown you the power of data visualization and
why you should use it every day.